unsere inspiration auf der wii kommt von
juliana der 29 jährigen berlinerin die
über nacht weltweit berühmt wurde bei
instagram postet sie videos in denen die
gebürtige senegalese auf rollschuhen
tanzt und dabei unglaublich cool und
unbeschwert aussieht am 22 juni hatte
uni dann einen 52 sekunden langen clip
hochgeladen den sängerin alicia keys
teilte und von stars wie top model
gisele bündchen kommentiert wurde
durch diese prominente unterstützung ist
der account der berlinerin innerhalb
kürzester zeit von 54.000 follower auf
inzwischen fast 800 tausend follower
angestiegen entdeckt hat um ihre
leidenschaft schon vor vielen jahren als
sie auf einen rollstuhl des ku band ging
und sich sofort in das so genannte jam
skating verliebt hat unter james skating
versteht man ein afrikanisch
amerikanischen skating style mit einem
mix aus tanz hip hop und gymnastik heute
hat sie ihr hobby zum beruf gemacht sie
gibt unterricht und organisiert roller
discos wir finden uni zuzuschauen macht
gute laune und fühlt sich nach sommer an
[Musik]